is that people's courage in this regard
gets contagious,
and so although I and the other journalists with whom I was working
were certainly aware of the risk —
the United States continues to be the most powerful country in the world
and doesn't appreciate it when you
disclose thousands of their secrets
on the Internet at will —
seeing somebody who is a 29-year-old
ordinary person who grew up in
a very ordinary environment
exercise the degree of principled courage that Edward Snowden risked,
knowing that he was going to go to prison for the rest of his life
or that his life would unravel,
inspired me and inspired other journalists
and inspired, I think, people around the world,
including future whistleblowers,
to realize that they can engage in that kind of behavior as well.
BG: I'm curious about your relationship with Ed Snowden,
because you have spoken with him a lot,
and you certainly continue doing so,
but in your book, you never call him Edward,
nor Ed, you say "Snowden." How come?
GG: You know, I'm sure that's something
for a team of psychologists to examine. (Laughter)
I don't really know. The reason I think that,
one of the important objectives that he actually had,
one of his, I think, most important tactics,
was that he knew that one of the ways
to distract attention from the substance of the revelations
would be to try and personalize the focus on him,
and for that reason, he stayed out of the media.
He tried not to ever have his personal life
subject to examination,
and so I think calling him Snowden
is a way of just identifying him as this important historical actor
rather than trying to personalize him in a way
that might distract attention from the substance.
Moderator: So his revelations, your analysis,
the work of other journalists,
have really developed the debate,
and many governments, for example, have reacted,
including in Brazil, with projects and programs
to reshape a little bit the design of the Internet, etc.
There are a lot of things going on in that sense.
But I'm wondering, for you personally,
what is the endgame?
At what point will you think,
well, actually, we've succeeded in moving the dial?
GG: Well, I mean, the endgame for me as a journalist
is very simple, which is to make sure
that every single document that's newsworthy
and that ought to be disclosed
ends up being disclosed,
and that secrets that should never have been kept in the first place
end up uncovered.
To me, that's the essence of journalism
and that's what I'm committed to doing.
As somebody who finds mass surveillance odious
for all the reasons I just talked about and a lot more,
I mean, I look at this as work that will never end
until governments around the world
are no longer able to subject entire populations
to monitoring and surveillance
unless they convince some court or some entity
that the person they've targeted
has actually done something wrong.
To me, that's the way that privacy can be rejuvenated.
BG: So Snowden is very, as we've seen at TED,
is very articulate in presenting and portraying himself
as a defender of democratic values
and democratic principles.
But then, many people really find it difficult to believe
that those are his only motivations.
They find it difficult to believe
that there was no money involved,
that he didn't sell some of those secrets,
even to China and to Russia,
which are clearly not the best friends
of the United States right now.
And I'm sure many people in the room
are wondering the same question.
Do you consider it possible there is
that part of Snowden we've not seen yet?
GG: No, I consider that absurd and idiotic.
(Laughter) If you wanted to,
and I know you're just playing devil's advocate,
but if you wanted to sell
secrets to another country,
which he could have done and become
extremely rich doing so,
the last thing you would do is take those secrets
and give them to journalists and ask journalists to publish them,
because it makes those secrets worthless.
People who want to enrich themselves
do it secretly by selling secrets to the government,
but I think there's one important point worth making,
which is, that accusation comes from
people in the U.S. government,
from people in the media who are loyalists
to these various governments,
and I think a lot of times when people make accusations like that about other people —
"Oh, he can't really be doing this
for principled reasons,
he must have some corrupt, nefarious reason" —
they're saying a lot more about themselves
than they are the target of their accusations,
because — (Applause) —
those people, the ones who make that accusation,
they themselves never act
for any reason other than corrupt reasons,
so they assume
that everybody else is plagued by the same disease
of soullessness as they are,
and so that's the assumption.
(Applause)
BG: Glenn, thank you very much. GG: Thank you very much.
BG: Glenn Greenwald.
(Applause)